madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
madame la Première ministre après le
rejet inédit du projet de loi sur
l'immigration vous êtes sur le point de
commettre
l'irréparable depuis plusieurs jours les
pires tractations politicienne ont lieu
dans la Hu clos de Matignon et de
l'Élysée au mépris de la séparation des
pouvoirs vous
instrumentaliser la CMP pour contourner
le Parlement et conclure coûte que
igné sur les du remblement
National madame la Première
ministre mesurez bien votre
responsabilité historique l'élection du
président Macron dev nous prémunir des
pires avan du programme de l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui de bouclier vous êtes
devenu le
[Applaudissements]
marchepiedvezur question aussi
essentielle que l'aide médicale d'État
le droit du sol le droit au prestation
sociale la déchéance de
nationalité mes chers collègues de la
majorité la seule position juste c'est
de tenir bon sur le respect des droits
fondamentaux c'est de refuser toute
disposition discriminatoire mes chers
collègues ne succombez pas au fantasme
véhiculé par l'extrême droite qui se
délecte aujourd'hui deor
une vioire idéique majeure mes chers
collègues je vous le dis solennellement
vous allez écrire ce soir une page de
notre histoire l'histoire d'un pays qui
en ce 19 décembre renoncerit à ses
valeurs
humanistes madame la Première ministre
mes chers collègues il est encore temps
de vousaisir n'outez pas leshonneur à la
compromission laissz pas ce texte de la
honte fracturer de manière durable notre
République et Ren les valeurs humiste de
notre
pays je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président chassigne j'ai
beaucoup de respect monsieur le
Président chassigne pour vous-même et
pour votre groupe mais moi je ne peux
pas laisser dire n'importe quoi sur le
contenu de notre texte je ne peux pas
laisser dire n'importe quoi et en vous
écoutant monsieur président chassigne
j'en viens me demander si vous avez lu
le texte dont il est question alors si
alors sortez sortez des slogans des
postures en voulant faire croire en
voulant faire l'amalgame entre notre
texte et les positions de l'extrême
droite les mots les mots ont un sens
monsieur les mots ont un sens monsieur
le Président chassigne l'extrême droite
c'est le rejet des étrangers par
principe parce qu'ils sont étrangers
l'extrême droite c'est la préférence
nationale nous nous croyons à
l'intégration par le travail nous nous
voulons nous nous voulons continuer à
former des talents et à diffuser notre
culture en accillant des étudiants
internationaux l'extrême
droite l'extrême droite l'extrême droite
c'est le refus d'accueillir même ceux
qui sont en danger le droit d'asile
c'est au cœur de nos valeurs monsieur le
Président chassigne alors ce qui est
dans le texte ce qui est dans le texte
c'est l'interdiction de placer les
mineurs en rétention administrative
c'est une mesure forte la gauche pas
fait ce qui est dans le texte ce qui est
dans le texte c'est la régularisation de
celles et ceux qui travaillent sans
avoir besoin de l'accord de l'employeur
la gauche ne l'a pas fait ce qui est
dans le texte ce sont des sanctions
fermes contre les passeurs contre les
marchands de sommeil qui profitent des
personnes fragiles la gauche ne l'a pas
fait monsieur le Président chassigne
laanupess est bien mal placé pour faire
des procès en compromission avec extrême
droite c'est la nupes qui fait en
permanence des appels du pied au
rassemblement national c'est la nupes
qui vote avec lui c'est la nuupesse avec
sa motion de rejet qui a bloqué le débat
main dans la main avec le rassemblement
national alors soyez clair face à
l'extrême droite face à l'extrême droite
la nuupesse est dans la collision nous
nous la combattons et avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur et mon gouvernement avec
la majorité nous défendons ce projet de
loi parceil est né silence on nentend
rien s'il vous
plaît nous défendons ce projet de loi
parce qu'il est efficace nous défendons
ce projet de loi parce qu'il est
conforme aux valeurs que j'ai toujours
porté aux valeurs porté par le Président
de la République depuis 2017 au valeur
républicaines
[Applaudissements]
je remercie madame la Première
ministre